the first day I was a product manager I
was a little nervous about what my life
and career would be but now I know that
it was the right role for me and it
totally might be the right role for you
as well
[Music]
[Applause]
I've been a product manager for about
eight years in the consumer travel space
I'd say the life of a product manager
over time it's something that I've grown
even more passionate about
thank you
[Music]
I go into the office three days a week
on Mondays and Fridays I'm at home
[Music]
a product manager is ultimately
responsible for the success of the
product they're the person who is the
liaison between a bunch of different
internal functions let's say product
design engineering Marketing sales and
ultimately what they do is they create a
story or a narrative to convince the
company and the greater world that the
thing that the team is working on will
drive the business forward
the first meeting of the day is stand up
the engineers on the team the designers
and myself will provide a brief update
on what we've been working on as well as
things that are blocking our progress
okay great yeah I'm glad we figured out
that blocker I feel like you would have
been stuck on that for like two weeks at
this point so it's a really good way to
first thing in the morning kind of
connect with your teammates because at
the end of the day we're all working
together towards a shared goal
hey everyone okay so here's what I'm
thinking that we should prioritize today
every two weeks we have a meeting called
Sprint planning a Sprint is a set period
of time where the team will work on a
series of user stories a user story is
basically one change and it's oftentimes
defined by both me the designers and the
engineers and I'll walk the engineering
team through all of the things that we
want to ship try to move around that
other story and focus on this one
instead because I think it's going to
impact one of our power users each of
the engineers will then provide some
input they'll say something like I think
this will take one week I think this
will take two months so how many story
points do you think that is based off of
that we'll break each of those things
down into smaller and smaller user
stories until each engineer has a full
enough plate to keep them busy for the
next two weeks and what's exciting about
Sprints is you get this sense of
accomplishment after two weeks that
you've shipped something that your end
users will benefit
so when we launched this uh what kind of
QA are you thinking we should do I also
have a lot of cross-functional meetings
and they come in two flavors the first
flavor is cross-functional meetings when
it comes to a specific project here are
the folks that I'm working with in order
to ship something soon let me get
analytics opinion on this and then the
second flavor is cross-functional
meetings with leaders of certain groups
or departments and in that case it's a
little bit more about making sure that
those leaders fully understand
everything from timelines to the
reasoning behind certain decisions and
that they're comfortable with the
direction that the team is going in
okay so here's where I think we need to
focus today the work life of a product
manager can sometimes be a little hectic
every day someone is relying on you to
know the answer to something and you
have to be an expert in your field we
need to uh break it down even further
like how does this part of the product
work I just want to make sure that we're
thinking about this from a business
standpoint too as well let me set up
some time this afternoon for us to walk
through it it's my responsibility to be
able to facilitate a communication or
just an outrage to the right people
within the company
let's get started designer view is a
meeting that happens weekly in this
meeting everyone will talk about pixel
level feedback let's double check to
make sure that the character account
will fit the screen properly
where should this button be should it be
different on our website versus on our
native apps and it's super fun because
you get to see this idea now presented
in a way that actual users will see
before you start writing code I have a
couple follow-up questions can we talk
about it over coffee maybe
[Music]
so how is this going so far
I'll really try to meet everyone that I
work closely with in some form of
one-on-one session probably once every
two weeks and a lot of times once every
week okay definitely hear you talking to
them about updates on what the team has
been working on concerns I might have
around certain strategic directions I'll
also just be like hey how are you doing
we can just talk through it
cool I think this is where you gain a
lot of trust and I really like to
leverage this also in the space of just
morale and motivation
works up an appetite I guess right on
the days that I'm in the office I use
this as a bit of a social touch point so
I'll ask someone that I work with hey
you want to go and grab lunch
[Music]
between meetings one of the things I
really enjoy doing is keeping up with
industry Trends and I'm mainly looking
for things like are people using our
product in ways that they enjoy that I'm
not thinking about as a product manager
It's Your Role to stay connected with
your community and your audience seems
like a pretty interesting idea
concept review is one of the most
exciting meetings of the week because
it's a forum for a team to basically
pitch an idea and that idea will come
equipped with data user research and
possible Concepts
between Concepts A and B which one do
you think is the one that will be the
least interruptive to the user
experience the collective Brain Trust of
the product managers the designers and
the engineering leaders will then offer
feedback it serves two purposes you can
communicate to everyone else while
you're working on and also you can kind
of justify the fact that you're spending
the next month on this one project love
it this one's great I say that we run
this test and see which one of the
variants ends up winning
I especially love working on products or
features that I would like to use myself
of course not trying to be biased
because I'm not all of our users but
it's just really exciting to be able to
get paid honestly for something that
you're so passionate about have a good
rest of the evening
hopefully this gave you a good sense of
what my day is like as a product manager
maybe it's even something that you're
interested in pursuing at some point in
your career
[Music]